okay i have a two-part question for you
first part is who would play you in a
movie about your life danger day kim oh
my god artie perfect answer i love him
he's an incredible actor the second part
is
is this movie going to be a biopic so
start of your life to present day or
should we focus in on a particular
chapter of your life that you think
would make a great movie to the extent
that there is a storyline that should be
made into a movie uh it is my
presidential campaign because that was
hilarious
[Laughter]
so someone definitely needs to make this
movie i mean
and this is a plug too so the first
third of my book uh is about the
presidential campaign and you know like
i thought it was pretty funny um and
then my campaign manager zach is writing
a full-on book about it uh that's going
to come out early next year that
needs to be made into a movie of some
kind or a tv series that sounds great
it's just really really funny it's true
to life so i i think that that if you
were to do a a biopic most of my life is
pretty dull up until then well except
for cty where you crushed it uh i mean
who the hell wants to you know
watch like the least nerdy nerd running
around summer camp i mean that's not
exactly i think a lot of people i
honestly there's a lot of people there's
a lot of different types of content that
could get made but i agree that i think
your presidential run would make a
fantastic movie also your campaign
manager zack from connecticut good
people good people coming from
connecticut so that i think that that's
where it should go it'll be like danger
day kim reflecting on
his uh rise to the presidency
and then people be like wait a minute
you didn't win and be like
yeah yeah alternate ending this is the
director's cut
the director is andre yang that's right
you know one of the jokes i told on the
trail was this is the simulation where
we win
i love that do you think we're living in
a simulation currently
like if push came to shove yes or no
what do you think mathematically you
would say we probably are right and i've
had some experiences too that suggests
that we are what's an experience that
suggests you're living in a simulation
well alexis keep keep in mind you're
talking to a guy who ran for president
united states and that is true and
became a nationally recognized figure in
the process so if anyone would look up
and say this is definitely a simulation
it would be someone like me because my
life has been so singularly weird
of my own making sort of yeah but it's
it's not the kind of thing that works
ordinarily so from my perspective it
definitely feels like i'm living in some
either
fictionalized world of someone's
creation uh yes it's like something you
feel wow not at the same scale as you
but i really relate to that feeling
sometimes where i'm like i look around
and i think is this really is this okay
all right yeah i mean if it's a
simulation works for me i'm having a
great time i'm so glad you're having a
great time i'm generally having a great
time too i mean that certainly there
have been some very stressful periods
over the last several years but
generally you know like super happy yeah
i agree with that well i think uh
there's a phrase that i really love
which some of the stuff i i know this
makes me sound like a total pollyanna
but it's not happy people who are
grateful it's grateful people who are
happy yeah i love it i love that you
probably do the same thing i do it's
like i have a gratitude list and anytime
i'm down i just look at my phone and
it's a list of things i'm grateful for
like you know number one is like
my wife my two is like you know
my my first son number three is my
second son
but then there's some random things on
there alexis yep like what my favorite
pizza place uh like there's one thing
there it says that i've achieved many of
my goals without having to destroy my
soul in the process like yeah i've like
random things like that listed that i i
can still get out and play basketball
uh you know like somewhat competitively
uh yeah which which is something that
that i'm proud of so they're like things
where it's like oh i am grateful for
that i'm grateful for that too like you
know some of them are kind of minor and
dumb but yeah that always makes me feel
better to your point that grateful
people are happy so anyone listening to
this if you're down and i know sometimes
it's hard not to be down in this day and
age just make yourself a list of things
you're grateful for and add something to
it every once in a while at any time
yeah you're down at the dumps just refer
to it and will help and that's not just
me saying so that's like that's data
because this stuff totally works right
we're nothing if not data backed so i
would agree 100
andrew okay so this is the question that
i've actually never asked before but i'm
curious what is the least expensive item
in your home that brings you the most
joy so i'm drinking a bubble tea as we
have this conversation oh really
expensive it's maybe like 4.90 i can
show it to you
amazing what's your bubble tea order
almonds 30 sugar or less ice okay if
they have almond milk tea which sure
most do
and then after that just traditional
multi same i tend to skip bubbles i swap
i was gonna ask i swap in red beans for
bubbles oh really yes i just like red
beans i have a confession to make about
bubble tea which is that i
i don't like it it's too sweet for me we
must cease this conversation immediately
so
so the thing i would say alexis yeah
tell me if you if you want to is you can
get 30 sugar or zero percent sugar and
you might like it more what is it then
though like if i were to say no sugar it
sounds to me like it would just be tea
with milk yeah doesn't that sound
delightful
[Laughter]
you know what you got me there that's a
really good point okay so what is the
most memorable gift you've ever received
or given either or hmm
yeah gifts
are you a good gift giver you know i
used to be above average and now well
well well below average
really poor i would say
so my wife just turned 40 and i managed
to rally and be like a reasonably good
husband okay and so like i i planned uh
you know party and it was like uh nice i
had like you know fairly touching speech
fairly touching well okay amazing
it was funny too oh okay good but it's
been like a very very dry period for me
in terms of my gift-giving and
thoughtfulness which i you know i'm
super grateful that evelyn's let me get
away with this for a little while but
before then if you rewind way back i was
pretty good uh so i'm thinking about the
things i did when i was pretty good why
do you think you used to be better at
giving gifts than you are now so i used
to be
kind of
an anxious shy introverted figure who'd
like look at people around me and like
be scared to talk to
uh to girls and so then you'd become
like mildly obsessed with what other
people
would like uh i suppose and so i was the
person who would be frankly probably
like a little bit cloying or creepy
really
wait wait wait i'll do the invitation
like i see you like this thing
oh my god
i mean i wasn't like that but but but
that's like the imitation of someone
who's like a little bit too
attentive and i was very sensitive when
i was young so during that time
you know i would care a lot about
various things i would buy people but
you know i remember as a teenager i'd
like buy girls i i was crushing on like
jewelry that made no sense like stuff
like that oh wow you're like oh wow that
is pretty bad no no i'm just i was
honestly i was like for a teenager i
feel like buying jewelry that's like a
nice gift as we just established first
of all no one is buying me any gifts
other than mix cds to put me in the
friend zone but yeah i think jewelry
from a teenager is a nice gift but it
depends who it's coming from yeah no i'm
thinking about when i was younger and
then i'm thinking about when evelyn and
i were together before i entered my now
unmindful zone um and so what changed
for me
is that over the last several years my
schedule and energies have just become
very very outward public facing and so
i'll just give you the the real life
example so i'm on the road running for
president i come back to the family like
you know one two days a week and that
like i stick my head in and then i have
no idea what's going on and if there's
an occasion like i don't know and if it
and let's say it was one of my child's
birthday like i don't know it was his
birthday but it's not i wasn't all like
part of the planning so i'd get there
there'd be like a party that i just kind
of showed up to so
and again my family has been awesome and
and loving and supportive but i i
haven't exactly been winning like
husband of the year dad of the year
competitions um over the last
several several years it would shock me
to learn that you had been how could one
singular person possibly do all of those
things at the same time thank you for
being understanding um really i just
thank evelyn for being understanding
over this past period of time so in
terms of
gifts that i am proud of or remember i
got my brother-in-law shinola watch i
was like proud of that at the time
shinola made in detroit yeah so as part
of venture from america i spent a lot of
time and i'm friendly with uh the
channel on the team uh the founder is a
great guy
named tom cartsodis and he truly started
chinola just to try and you know do
something awesome and positive that's
great so there's a period when i bought
people shinola gifts and and i was proud
of that shinola watch because i think my
brother-in-law really likes it and he
wears it to this day that's really nice
shinola was actually a part of a
gift-giving tradition at the last
company i worked for in tech patreon
where my manager who is now a good
friend of mine actually brenda morris
he's also been on the podcast he
bought all of us like new shinola
notebooks on our first day and so then
when i became a manager i started buying
new shinola notebooks for all of my
direct reports on their first day and so
it became a nice little tradition to
give like this nice notebook to your new
hire
that's lovely i really love shinola uh
and if you go to their their retail
locations it's uplifting and you know
the stuff genuinely is made in the u.s
and i've been to the facilities in
detroit i think that they're
doing something really positive
[Music]
you